[Musik]
hallo leute
wie ihr seht den thurgau mich hier bei
uns dann morath versetzt hat eigentlich
wollte timo rath ihren video drehen und
er ist nicht aufgetaucht dann habe der
tolga nicht gesagt so jetzt probiere
messen ob wir das hinbringen aber
bisschen aufgeregt
er probiert jetzt einfach ohne mach es
als überraschung wenn es was wird ist
toll
biostatistik
okay jetzt sieht man mal ganz ernst und
mache das jetzt wir brauchen für so was
machen sie
denn ganz einfaches rezept wo man machen
kann wenn es schnell gehen soll oder
wenn man sich so überlegt was konkret
denn heut dann ist das rezept und zwar
nennt sich das würstchen akku ganz
ruckzuck und ich finde die zutat dass
sie recht gesund und es ist
überschaubarer und sauber und es geht
halt einfach flott und man hört was auf
dem tisch und kann wenn man mag
vielleicht noch in salaten grüner dazu
mache so wir brauchen dazu 700 gramm
zucchini 500 gramm kartoffeln zwei große
zwiebel vier würstchen wir haben hier
inzwischen genommen
butterschmalz zwei esslöffel 2 ist mit
viel mehl 500 milliliter oder 500 gramm
gemüsebrühe
220 gramm sahne
zwei esslöffel senf salz pfeffer besteht
solange anja ich schneidig zwiebeln
kartoffeln und
keine zwiebeln
so zweimal gleich an zu weinen ja denn
jetzt haben einige trotzdem ab und meine
matura schwimmt mir die wange untersagen
[Musik]
die hatte sei
schwierig machten was mir aber
krimidinner gemacht das war vielleicht
lustig krimidinner das ist ein spiel der
kriegst du praktisch nick hatte und dann
weißt du
und dann
und dann weißt du brauchst nicht was du
für eine rolle hast in diesem krimi tina
da wird einer durch einer ermordet wurde
und dann musste es praktisch
ausgefallen wäre bei der mutter ist und
in diesem krimi die naht gibt es aber
gibt es essen dabei also es gibt eine
vorspeise hauptspeise
wohnen die sehr mit der papi ich
ermordet da waren eine pizzeria besitzer
und ich war die tara bist du also also
italienisch spanischen zaragoza und
meine rolle war ich war nie eine frau
die mit ihren reizen spielen könnte
was wir gemacht haben
[Gelächter]
die müssen wir aber waren es ist so
lustig man hat zu acht spielen können
und
meine freundin war die die witwe
praktisch und dem verstorbenen und es
war immer so lustig war steht dann immer
und ich war dann irgendwann noch von
jenen von den von dem verstorbenen war
ich noch schwanger das hat sich dann
herausgestellt im laufe diesen abriss
und dann
nicht an
da müsste ja gute schauspieler ist zwar
rechtlich zu beschneiden kartoffeln
würden wir haben in welche bieten würfe
[Musik]
so bedürfte jetzt alles wissen und mit
dem unterschied dass man sicher richtig
toll weil es könne auch klappt oose
intolerante benutzern und haben brutalen
dann den leckerer buttergeschmack hinter
gerichtet wenn man kann mit
butterschmalz pfarrer franz körper dann
aber beim chor und man kann es
wesentlich höher erhitzt wie jetzt
richtige butter
in die pfanne
[Musik]
formal nur noch die zucchini dazu
wenn man das jetzt alles schön
angebrachte habe dann machen wir noch
die gemüsebrühe und lasse das ganze 20
minuten küche
das mädel
dramatischen wasser aus einer spanne
[Gelächter]
eigentlich hätte ich das mehr über das
gemüse macher solar und dann erst ablöse
aber da ich das jetzt oder richter sitz
verteilt man das jetzt anders da die
schleuse bis link kaltes wasser das auf
dass die blümchen weg sind und dann mach
ich's raina damit genau das ist ein
bisserl anliegt und die 20 minuten sind
um
wir können jetzt hier weitermache dann
guck mal
dieses gericht wird sich eigentlich so
bitte die besonderheit in dem gericht
mit eigelb regiert das bedeutet es wird
angedickt mit eingeben und man muss nur
darauf achten dass der akku nicht mehr
kocht es das sei aber nicht mehr gucken
den sch'tis eigelb zu schnell stoppt und
halter
fest wird dann ja vermittelt auch immer
das neue mit sahne und
es kommt dann hier rein
da kommt jetzt an der senf
heimbacher die würstel ende zu jetzt
machen wir noch ein bisschen warm dass
die wir stehen unternehmen
durch zöllner und dann ist auch schon
fertig
[Musik]
wir haben es jetzt verstärkung geholt
okay die dürfen wir probieren mit mehl
zucker hat wir sind fertig glas ist
fertig ich war von mir passt am besten
die
[Musik]
kommt ihr
[Gelächter]
nein
das von ihr selbst strenge und darf mir
bei martin streng zu sein
ok ich bringe
[Gelächter]
und
zucchini kartoffeln mit würstchen
bitteschön
ich muss sagen ich weiß dass es ist zwar
nicht wenig
ich weiß das ist kurz und ich habe es ja
noch nie zu viel jetzt einmal
ausprobieren
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
und essen die kinder denn es geht
schnell und ist schon
[Musik]
ich
verdiene ich das okay da sind heute
übrigens dass ich deswegen hat er
schuldig
hier sind wir eingesprungen und
ich muss gestehen ich hatte in der tat
mit meinen kindern ein das eine kind war
krank hat gerüchte sich die gasag durch
den hochschul übergeben dann bett frisch
bezogen dann kommt katze ins bett dann
kommt es andere kind ins bett was sieht
es mir bestimmt ein
gutes ende märz über das passt
[Gelächter]
ist davon abgesessen wenn es euch
gefallen hat guckt gerne nach ich würde
mich darüber freue lassen
wir sind jetzt im team